we're rolling
the the best advice I ever got was you
don't get what you don't ask for have
courage and be kind that's up on my wall
in my house that's where my favorite
quotes of all time
so when I was a kid my mom and I would
speak on the phone and whenever I was
feeling about tai or angst about
something I call her and wear this thing
KLB and she still said there's none
personally whenever I thought it means
keep laid-back there's nothing like a
female friendship I have boyfriends who
I adore but compared to my girlfriends
that crap I think the best piece of
advice I've ever been given is actually
a quote from Winston Churchill just keep
buggering on it's pull up your socks and
get on with it I used to have a really
weird life mantra which was from
Muhammad Ali and that was freedom
through discipline to develop a thick
skin
of greatness
from a blonde who I kind of based myself
on and that is Miss Piggy and she always
said never eats more than coolant and
I'm going with that that whatever
happens in the day I can handle it
to be happy in yourself to love yourself
and to always put yourself first unless
you have a child and to them first but
first and foremost yourself yes yourself
life is precious and it's really simple
but it's that's what I love about it
it's just a great reminder every day the
best keys will arise that I can give is
to where to meet you
okay not have all the answers right now
like it's enjoy the process of getting
of struggling with things and a whipsaw
way don't they it's obviously you know
good to go through bad times but just
knowing that it's all right not to have
everything figured out the best piece of
advice I ever had was from a writer and
I said I wanted to do and look at white
as block or whatever it's called and I
don't know what to write about and she
said of all right about that she said
don't stop